Speaker 1: So let's now get from strategy
and approach.
To Tactics.
I got a really interesting email from Eric
and Colleen, I think Eric and Colleen are
a couple that watch the show, and what Eric
and Colleen wrote to me about was the new
democratic talking points.
They seem to understand that Democrats have
been falling to Republicans in many cases
because Republicans much more effectively
play on fear and anger, and that Republican
talking points just naturally lend themselves
more to that.
And Eric and Colleen wrote to me and said,
David, you know, if you if we want to develop
on the left the same motivating fear and anger
that the Republican Party does.
We need to change our messaging.
Now, Eric and Colleen say it doesn't even
matter if our messaging is true.
Republicans lie all the time.
So my question to you as I go through these
possible talking points that Eric and Colleen
suggested is how do we feel about using talking
points that we know in some cases aren't true?
Is that taking the low road and we don't want
to do it, but here are the new talking points
that Eric and Colleen suggest should be repeated
and repeated and repeated in 2022 and 2024
on abortion.
Okay, these are hypothetical talking points
Republicans want to force you to have babies
and they will create a dangerous and expensive
black market of back alley abortions.
It's not really an exaggeration, actually,
it's using maybe hyperbolic language, but
that one isn't wrong on guns.
Republicans will make it so easy to get guns
that every criminal will be armed, and many
of those will be armed with semi-automatic
outfitted with high-capacity magazines.
Every criminal will be armed.
It's an exaggeration, but certainly the right
wants to make it really easy to get guns on
immigration.
Republicans will shut down the borders.
Women and children who are fleeing violence
are going to die at the border of disease
and starvation or be sent back to death in
their home countries.
Tipper Bolick But it plays on fear and it
plays on anger education.
Republicans will take control away from school
boards and implement a federal government
curriculum.
It won't be based on science.
It won't be based in accurate historical realities.
It's going to be alternative facts, lies and
Christianity, and they will impose it on your
children.
OK, on the pandemic, Republicans will not
allow enforcement of any safety measure.
They will ban mask requirements, they will
ban vaccine requirements, and they are going
to allow this or a future pandemic to run
rampant.
They will allow innocent Americans to keep
dying just to avoid implementing any regulations
on deregulation.
Republicans are going to let poison and sewage
pour into our water systems.
They're going to build more fossil fuel plants
near your homes, and there will be more respiratory
disease and cancer as a result on inequality.
Republicans will allow wealth concentration
to deepen, and it will destroy the middle
class.
That one seems just pretty, pretty sober,
actually.
On taxes, Republicans will continue to allow
the rich and corporations to get away with
paying no taxes or close to it.
The rich will get richer, concentration of
power will become worse, and it will crush
the middle class.
And lastly, on infrastructure, the talking
point proposed by Eric and Colleen is our
infrastructure, roads, electrical grid, military
educational system.
It will be bankrupt thanks to the rich and
corporations paying almost no taxes.
This is more hyperbolic language than Democrats
and the Left tend to use.
It's mostly accurate with some exaggerations.
How do you feel about it?
Are these do Democrats and does the left need
to find talking points to generate that exact
same type of fear and anger that the right
does without and out lies?
And if the answer is yes, the left needs to
do that.
Does the left need to do it without exaggeration
and without hyperbole?
Or is it OK to do it the way Eric and Colleen
are suggesting?
Let me know your thoughts.
Let me know what talking points you think
the left should adopt.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and we'll be back with more right after this.